[Music]
what do you want richard i'll be honest
with you
i want to do a good deed
[Music]
i want to do a lot more
the best things in life are free i try
to set an example for my nephew
anthony got kicked out of school i went
to all that trouble and for what i've
always been accused you're going to be
good that's what i want i want to do
whatever i can to help the family
money don't get everything it's true
what it don't get i can't use i want
money
i wonder what they talk about in there i
didn't catch the name [ __ ]
put him on the table
dick i just got this jacket
you know i try so hard
better do something about dickie
marasani
[Music]
i know you can get anything look at
dickie multisandy he steps up takes care
of his family takes care of all the
bases
if anybody tells anybody about this
how you doing on your merry patches
[Music]
i want to do all kinds of good things
it's the wanting
[Music]
pain comes from always wanting things
but what do i
know a murderer
the best things in life are free
i got myself a son hi christopher hello
[Music]
like a scam or something
some babies when they come into the
world know all kinds of things from the
other side
[Music]
you